foreign
this year we have once again seen the
climate change affects us all
thousands lost their lives in
catastrophes that are no longer rare
incidents but part of the new reality
people are struggling
and nature is suffering those who played
no part in creating the crisis stand to
suffer the most and the impact of
climate change is not the same
everywhere
in Europe we make commitments and stick
to them with the European green deal we
will cut our emissions by at least 55 by
2030 and become climate neutral by 2050.
we are helping other countries and their
people reduce their emissions switch to
clean renewable energy and adopt their
City's infrastructure and everyday life
to climate change
the EU and its member states are the
world's biggest donors of climate
Finance
in 2020 we mobilized 27 billion dollars
to help developing countries fight
climate change and get prepared
because our Destinies are intertwined
against climate change we can only win
together
we owe it to our children and
grandchildren to deliver on the future
we have promised